so like I was telling you guys earlier
usually I go and ask people questions
but today I thought it would be cool if
I just went out and filmed people and
things that I find you yeah oh my thank
you thank you
I love you
nice
[Music]
thank you
okay what's going on are you feeling any
like okay oh hi people that I find
beautiful beautiful
thank you your other come and film
people one thing that I find beautiful
you think I'm beautiful
Sam beautiful yeah
I talking about
okay thank you you're gonna put it thank
you thank you
your company oh that's cute
sweet oh that's so sweet
oh let's see
Oh
babies
oh okay that's pretty much it
in Korea
all right I think I know what you're
doing I just got asked thank you every
sheet good two cards that's it okay
so what are we looking at today oh my
gosh I'm not quick enough for that one
thank you how does it feel it feels
great it feels really good when people
say that too but it's okay
it feels great we are appreciated yeah
[Music]
if he's nice a lot of opportunities come
out and it makes me feel good you feel
beautiful I didn't vote all the time I'm
glad to look the way I look and yeah I'm
happy to feel confident in my own skin
so what do you think is the most
beautiful thing about him
around him
I don't know I like everything
I'm obsessed with him the fact that
she's alive that I'm able to spend these
moments with her in this beautiful
garden you know
I appreciate her a lot
[Music]
I thought I'd switch things up today and
just go out and film people and things
that I find you
[Music]
I don't know what to do in this that's
sweet thank you
thank you
[Music]
appreciate that beautiful that's so nice
you see these all the time and I was
like that's not really well you should
be filming yourself
[Music]
that is such a good project it looks
like really nice thank you so nice oh my
god okay
so I need and I need something to work
with they're not what what is it that
what what what do people usually how do
they usually react but I'm switching
things up completely today and I'm just
going out and filming people that I
think are beautiful why be able to
I think what you do is beautiful as well
yeah I think it takes a lot of courage
[Music]
I was crying so I just tried to figure
out
thank you okay
[Music]
okay
[Music]
thank you thank you so much
you're the same nope that's it I have
tiny eyes cuz I'm a giant I don't think
I'm beautiful
beautiful
[Music]
what a fun idea
[Music]
thank you I appreciate that
are you trying to see the reaction that
he's telling
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
okay I feel like I've never heard
someone describe me as beautiful but I
appreciate it
[Music]
I appreciate that I just think oh my
gosh I literally like I was trying on
dresses before and like my rib wasn't
fitting in there I was like should I
believe like leave a rib but thank you
[Music]
it's like I was telling you earlier
usually I go up to people and ask some
questions but today I'm doing something
completely different I thought it'd be
fun to go out and film people that I
think are beautiful oh that's really
sweet thank you thank you
okay
hudsmith spotter in awesome that's
really nice to be I appreciate that
thank you
oh my goodness you're so sweet okay so
who no there's no question oh that was
very sweet
[Music]
[Music]
my daughter's your daughters what okay
that's really uncomfortable for me the
like here and out but thank you okay why
didn't come
it's not a word I hear thank you oh
thank you
I made my day thank you so much
[Music]
so to me
[Music]
Oh wonderful Thank You Elmo nice
[Music]
that's great yeah like that
[Music]
thank you thank you so much so nice
thank you people I think that I
oh thank you
Oh Sammy thank you
[Music]
be calling me beautiful home that's
flattering thank you okay
[Music]
oh okay thank you
thank you I guess then I don't know
house oregano buddy oh thank you I
appreciate it I think they're beautiful
thank you
okay thanks
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you you're very kind
[Music]
loke it's so crazy that you say this
because I just saw a video about this
I'm like wow that it's so empowering
like I totally want to do that any lady
just came to me into the exact same
thing so talk about the spirit speaking
you totally right there yes thank you
I'm actually I think everyone's
beautiful and thrown away no matter what
so no you're worth that is my saying for
this year for sure oh sweet
oh okay
[Music]
anyways it really yeah wow that's a good
so what do I do anything just stand here
[Music]
oh thank you I appreciate it that's
awesome
wait including me or just Tim who knows
me um I appreciate it thank you so much
[Music]
that's very nice I like being told I'm
different
oh that's cute
I love that you just made my day I think
it's really awesome layered spread that
around
I don't know I would have known I don't
think so this is very awkward for me
because I like to that I like to talk
about myself at all
whenever I think of myself I try to ask
other people that know me very well
about me because I feel like everybody
else takes different interpretations of
the person why do you think you don't
like talking
because I don't want to sell for
centuries at all how does it feel to be
beautiful I feel like everybody's
beautiful but that was so sweet I did
not expect that by the way I thought I
was gonna be answering a question about
like you know what's my favorite color
or something my hair color is yellow how
does it feel to be beautiful feels
pretty good that's it that's an awesome
question I really like that I really
like that it feels
it feels precious it feels
I feel fortunate just you saying that
you're right I forget actually I forgot
I guess that's how it feels empowering
and fun I'm just curious how does it
feel to be beautiful oh oh okay
on the inside or the outside I inside I
feel cute
Barney outside not so much yes it's kind
of weird
Otakon got any more questions
how did it feel hearing that man it's so
we're like nobody comes up to me and say
hey you look beautiful it's so we're but
thank you but wow okay I don't know what
to do how does it feel to be beautiful
it feels really good to be able to hear
that and feel like it's true which
hasn't always been true so it feels
really good
well it's true right now yeah I noticed
we've got a little emotional and I'm
just curious why I'm just been having
like a really hard time lately with my
mental health and obviously that's
something that really affects like how I
feel on the outside you know especially
when I'm actually on my way to work so
you know especially when I come to
places like like my work and I feel like
I need to be a certain amount of peppier
or not I've engaged I definitely feel
like I have to dress up for that and
I didn't I didn't feel it today very
much but you know I was a little hard on
myself for that and I was like you know
I know that it's just how I'm feeling
and so external validation and made me
feel really good about that because it
made me remember like yeah you know I
was right to tell myself not to be too
hard on myself
[Music]
I don't know I mean it's like one of
those things that like you always want
to tell yourself but you don't know if
you ever fully believe it
oh well I take it for granted
oh I'm disappointed with it there you go
you feel beautiful yeah part of it
[Music]
if somebody said to me you are beautiful
yeah how do I feel awesome okay perfect
nobody's talked to me about that so I
want to hear about that yeah you're
beautiful
thanks so much Oh beauty thank you
that's it
so do you do you feel beautiful yes I'm
beautiful now
[Music]
it feels like I didn't expect that
question it feels good to hear it
beautiful yeah but by my girlfriend by
my family but not too often right now I
do know well I guess from your
perspective I am so thank you I I never
really felt that way so
thank you for if you're complimenting me
or otherwise no beautiful well no one
ever like tells you that I don't know
like is not something that you walk
thinking about and at least in my case
so when people tell you things like that
it's just like surprising obviously it
makes me nervous and it makes me smile
but I don't know I think sometimes it
makes me think about how other people
see you and the way that you see
yourself reflecting either in the mirror
or the water like just a reflection
instead of what others seeing you
[Music]
great I think it's hard to feel me why
do you say that society has different
standards in beauty sometimes I don't
feel like it if it
I don't know I don't know I've never
really been asked that question before
artists are not ask that questions been
told up before
I guess great not really I have some
self-esteem issues but who does it you
know
[Music]
thank you
I don't know how to answer that
[Music]
but thank you I'm just automatically
like brings a smile to your face oh they
do so much I don't know I don't I feel
like a normal person
oh my gosh thank you I'm I don't even
know what the answer is they're correct
yes sir
so I'm just curious how does it feel to
be beautiful
feels good good good
yes do you feel beautiful Oh see I'm
glam right now I'm Glenn right now this
isn't the average so I'll just say it's
very nice I don't know but it's nice
guys it's a big yeah
how does it feel to be beautiful shoot
photography wise a photographer I see
beauty and other people but for myself I
just don't really see myself like that
so it's kind of hard for me to like
explain that I just seeing other people
but for me just to get that compliment I
never get things like that's for me it's
like I can't really think of a time that
I got it it's oh Lord I felt like
beautiful I was trying to look good you
know how did it feel
I guess it feels great it feels good I
mean now I do I don't know how does it
feel like good I guess I don't know I've
never really felt beautiful no not
really I mean I've never thought I was
ugly but it was you know like average
[Music]
well I can say it feels wonderful
because I know that beauty is inside and
out and through my years I'm pretty
seasoned now so let's just
no it's nice when someone tells you bad
oh wow
I've never been asked this question
before well I'll take it as a compliment
I think it's very nice beautiful very
subjective question for you to ask are
you guys saying I am beautiful
oh that's very tough in my own way I
would say so sure my mom thinks I'm
beautiful that matters what I have one
question for you Matt and that is how
does it feel
that is a hard one to answer how does it
feel it feels weightless I suppose and
[Music]
just really warm to even be asked the
question the hard one it is still I do
now thanks
[Music]
feels really nice
[Music]
thanks sir yeah absolutely yeah
Beauty has a lot of colors
[Music]
cool good yeah do you think you're
beautiful yeah yeah you are
good job oh it's good so still the figs
beautiful yeah so how does it feel
hearing that you're beautiful
[Music]
do you feel beautiful oh yes I do yes
most of the time all the time
oh yes and I like myself I wouldn't
consider myself beautiful - thank you
for the compliment someone question for
you Lucas and that is how does it feel
to be beautiful I know that's first time
that's amazing
[Music]
after hear these I think yeah it feels
great for the inside out
I don't know how Phil oh I guess it
feels good it feels good when people
notice you and like beautiful like it
makes people around you feel good too
[Music]
huh I guess I don't know I'm just normal
like everybody else everybody's
beautiful beautiful yeah it's it's I'm
actually starting to realize that might
be true
[Music]
anyone heard of it I detect
yeah
that's an idea beautiful
I don't know I don't know that feels
like
it feels
like breathing it feels like being
existing being able to
oh okay well I don't think so but for
example when people tell me that I like
okay that's your
what you think but I'm doing the same
that your opinion is that a question
your pinion it's a struggle I guess I'm
just used to it thank you so much feels
good I guess
I feel fine I guess neutral
I don't know I really don't know how to
answer this video so I just don't know
how do you feel I'm feeling good now
thank you beautiful I mean it feels nice
when people tell me that that's a body
you know it's like give yourself
confidence and everything so it's really
nice honestly and thank you for that say
that I do
oh cool
I guess it feels pretty nice great
do you feel beautiful yeah I feel
beautiful sure I think that I'm
naturally good-looking I don't think I
do very much to make it better I guess I
go to the gym I don't know but I'm also
not like I'm not arrogant about that - I
don't think I'm the most beautiful
person on earth
or even close to be honest
but I think humans in general are kind
of beautiful how does it feel to be
beautiful fantastic alright thank you
that's a very nice way to give a
compliment
beautiful
I thank you that's really sweet of you
how does it feel to be beautiful um
can't relate but thank you I don't I
wouldn't know Oh what feels really good
that feels really good of course what do
you think the most beautiful thing
how much I wanted listen to people I'm
told about it I wouldn't know
I don't know is because for me it is
something like that
I had to had a surgery I oh really yeah
because my teeth look like this
so I always thought that I maybe not be
beautiful you know but my friends they
always said that and after that now I
hate myself so I feel that was the
mistake how does it feel to be beautiful
I had no idea well thank you maybe on
the inside but I don't ever feel it no
okay well I think you should thank you I
don't know what that means
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean yeah cuz you just said that I was
it's really nice it feels good feels
pretty good
makes me feel confident so I'm just
curious how does it feel to be beautiful
oh that's nice of you good
I don't know makes me feel good like I
have purpose what do you think it is
that makes you feel beautiful evening
caring less about what other people
think feels good yeah do you feel
beautiful this pretty good yeah yeah I
do what do you think um I think it's
just being in a good mood in a beautiful
place probably
feels great
satisfying and
[Music]
for real
[Music]
I don't wear a lot of makeup I don't
actually sew
don't really have to do anything in
order to feel that way just have a good
night of sleep if you arrest it and then
you
yeah if you think that I am beautiful
thank you I think it can be really
complicated because women can be really
mean to you and men won't take the time
to get to know your actual personality
that's if you're straight I am and
single get dinner
but it's complicated and I think that we
need to really focus on what's inside I
think I'm most beautiful inside and
outside is just like a artistic
expression of my personality so if
that's things that dope it does in shame
oh my god
oh my god
it feels good I think mostly feel
beautiful on the inside oh that's so
flattering glad thank you yeah beautiful
[Music]
well
that's a nice question usually I think
pretty instead of beautiful because
beautiful is such an intense word how
does it feel to be beautiful I guess you
must say I don't know if I should even
answer that haha
carried a weight over to smile I mean
you'd be beautiful oh oh that made me
feel good well when people compliment
you and tell you they're beautiful it
really warms up your heart it's
different when someone random tells you
because they don't know you they don't
see you every day they don't see when
you look ugly they don't see when you're
in PJs that's what's so for someone else
to tell you kind of feels like maybe
maybe I am somewhere pretty compared to
like when you just look at yourself in
the mirror so you know I think I'm
pretty
you actually someone else is actually
telling you
kind of magical different Wow
I think I mean nice I mean that's really
nice to say I don't know how to explain
it because I guess sometimes people
don't feel beautiful so when somebody
tells you where you're beautiful I don't
know you just feel confused but also
like happy yeah how does it feel to be
beautiful Oh
[Music]
oh yeah it's it's a deep question it's a
deep question yeah I don't I don't know
thank thank you thank you thank you for
us and I really don't know I'm just not
a confident person insecure in all
aspects why do you think you don't
oh I don't know cuz in Brazil like
you're consider York instead beautiful
if you were a blonde like blue eyes like
white skin and so in the stereotype and
I'm thinking just three small too so
I don't know where they think of myself
that way I was told that I have
beautiful feet once
those are odd compliment but don't take
it
I don't believe I am beautiful maybe
when I was young what no I don't believe
sister sigh I don't think I am so I
would've but I would hope that somebody
who it like really is I don't know just
feel happy because they are I don't know
oh I don't know talk today insert these
oh my god I'm so shy right now oh my god
I really don't know sorry I think I
[Music]
don't know what it is I'm sorry
[Music]
great thank you so much it's it's
probably probably I don't know I don't
have any snarky thing to say that's very
nice of you
beautiful thing about you
[Music]
it depends on the you that you're
referring to
[Music]
no I mean well they got me on guard I
guess yeah that's great I mean not to
sound there's assisting but you got to
love yourself no matter how you look was
persona was your character and so on and
so forth and therefore regardless of the
perceptions of what beauty is to other
people as long as if you're beautiful
within yourself when you're comfortable
in yourself then yes you're beautiful
and thank you for saying that beautiful
oh thanks
[Music]
I'm not sure only kind of tearing out
some nice actually like seen videos like
this but like I never knew that I'd be
asked that I don't know I guess it's
kind of like it's funny because I
sometimes like struggle with confidence
so like I usually don't feel as
so it's kind of nice being come
but it's definitely nice to you oh my
gosh
I don't really think of myself as that
but have you ever felt beautiful
sometimes yeah I guess so how does it
feel what do you do good sometimes I
feel like it shouldn't feel good to feel
like that
because it seems kind of superficial but
yeah I feel like it's definitely
something that especially girls I think
really value
so
how does it feel to be beautiful
I don't really think of myself as
beautiful but I have days when I feel
really good when I feel really good and
I feel beautiful and it's just it feels
like sunshine I think wow
I don't know that's quite a compliment
thank you very much do you feel
beautiful you know I do now explain to
me how it feels warm beautiful that's a
very sweet question you know how to
answer that
good I don't know you don't always see
yourself exactly how everybody else sees
you so you know when people say that or
ask you that question it's just kind of
like I don't know it feels good because
I don't know what to say I feel like I
have a beautiful life so that makes me
feel beautiful
[Music]
it feels really good it feels calming
it's good to remember that it's good
that you have other people to remind you
of that because not everybody it's not i
am always able to I don't hold on to
that thought you always feel insecure at
some points regardless of how pretty
someone really is but on the whole I'd
say it's very nice
to
[Applause]
being peace with your own beauty and be
happy how beautiful you are
feels pretty good wow that's so that's a
really really different different
perspective but it feels it feels
different it was very different
yeah because everyone's unique in their
own way so I like to say that I'm
different in a way and I'm beautiful
that way if you like me like me no no I
see I'm not no behind closed doors I'm
very very different but yeah I work on
everything all day I'm not exactly sure
I always thought I was California cute
not beautiful so oh I mean I don't know
it's kind of like I don't know like I
guess good thank you
that feels amazing and thank you I don't
feel beautiful but thank you
[Music]
um I don't know I don't really think
about it I guess um feels pretty good
thank you
[Music]
I do yeah thank you
well thank you looking at myself in the
mirror um something that I've had to
really deal with my whole life you know
just being handsome yeah it's it's great
it's a good time you know a lot of
opportunities hey guys it's over here
being beautiful no
Oh
I don't know grateful I'm blessed and I
appreciate it bein with awesome
thank you so much
thank you I don't know
good I guess the same
[Music]
Oh
and people don't say is that beauty is
in the eye of the beholder so it's a
humbling experience I guess oh thank you
oh my gosh I guess it feels great
amazing feels amazing I didn't think
that that's what this question was gonna
be but uh you know everyone's beautiful
and I think that that's actually an
awesome way making this video I think
that's super cool
it feels pretty amazing I guess when
people around me are beautiful I feel
beautiful
Oh Lots
that's a cute question I
[Music]
thank you I guess it's not of an answer
thank you you too and how do you feel
help someone's asking you that
[Music]
feels amazing thank you oh it's great I
feel happier I guess sometimes when I
feel beautiful but other than that
so do you think you feel happier because
you feel beautiful or you could be a
focus before the happier I feel
beautiful because I'm happier there it
is
but I know what has ever called me this
well beside my parents it feels nice it
feels comforting no no I'm turning
really pink beautiful Wow seems alright
you know everyone has their own you know
strengths and weaknesses you know beauty
comes from within the body I guess
not what's outside of you but how you
present yourself
so how did it make you feel when I call
you happy what's the difference between
the plans you feel beautiful well when I
stutter that's when I feel
Blair but when I don't I feel alright
[Music]
oh man thank you so much I feel
beautiful at times do you feel beautiful
most of the time around around the right
people I do so I'm just curious how does
it feel to be beautiful I gotta know
thank thank you good I love it it feels
good it feels great yeah I think
everyone should feel everyone should
wake up every morning and look in the
mirror and like what they see
oh I don't know I've never gotten us a
question before good I guess
thank you very considerate that thank
you
it feels nice to be complimented do you
feel beautiful at the moment I feel
pretty warm
I appreciate the conference thank you
well that's quite a compliment I don't
get called beautiful very often so I
suppose it feels good to be complimented
by you oh no no I think I feel handsome
how does it feel to be beautiful
[Applause]
great I guess I'm alive
that's beautiful it not make me blush a
little I don't know I guess a little
caught off guard I would say Oh
good I suppose it's not something I
would usually use to describe myself so
it's nice to hear someone else say it
that's really sweet thank you
[Music]
am I supposed to answer that you could
oh that's why do bad things it's pretty
grand feels all right
I guess it's guess it's just part of the
atmosphere
it's nice and beautiful here in the
world so it's good to feel beautiful in
the world and be contributing to it how
does it feel to be beautiful
[Music]
I think you have to be beautiful inside
because sometimes I know my outer face
doesn't show it but sometimes when I'm
really happy and glowing I feel
beautiful inside and I feel that inside
is important but also outside including
all the people that you see the
beautiful people that you see on the
outside
[Music]
great nose
amazing
everything feels a little brighter in
the world honestly it's really nice when
someone said that it's like different
when you like tell yourself that you're
beautiful but when someone like said it
to your face it just it's completely
different you're just like it's just
such a nice feeling even if it's like
from a guy or girl it's nice
that's what do you mean I'm not
beautiful so I can't answer this
question
oh just regular I guess maybe
good-looking
feels good doesn't feel bad you yeah it
feels healthy oh that's so nice um thank
you I guess it feels good wow that's so
sweet I love that okay good
it feels great not frequently but I feel
beautiful right now good good
I have a daughter who is three and ever
since she was born I made it like a
really really big goal in mind to
practice positive self-talk and have a
really good relationship with my body
and food and just like all of the things
that the world tells you to hate
yourself about like I consciously made
an effort because I don't want her to
grow up with a lot of the feelings that
I grew up with so um that has really
helped to practice
please
good
[Music]
thank you
feels like every sickle embarrassed and
makes me blush oh I didn't I think
beauty is subjective so someone says I'm
beautiful I hope they see me more like
for the inside of me than for the
outside but I do appreciate the
compliment but even if you'd be a
beautiful oh yeah yeah yeah
really beautiful right now I disagree
yeah you don't know oh yeah no beautiful
[Music]
well honestly I don't know like I don't
like really like it's hard to like look
in the mirror and like be confident
about yourself like that's that's just
like my opinion just because like I had
like a lot of like self doubts and
everything like I struggle with acne a
lot like as like a teenager
so like when it comes to like
considering myself like beautiful like
it mainly like helps like when I like
other people like saying it because like
in my mind it's kind of like a little
more negative compared to like what
other people like think thank you sir
but thank you how does it feel to be
beautiful
[Music]
do you feel beautiful yeah yeah you
don't know how to respond to that yeah
oh thank you I appreciate that I don't
know what to say I don't have an answer
to that
I feel phenomenal yeah all the time I'm
just wondering how did it feel to be
beautiful oh it's very good thank you
it's know how the fuel oh you're not
calling me I am talking you I was not
[Music]
it's good I've seen videos like this oh
god I always cry when I watch these kind
of videos and like I really get emotion
of this thing so I don't know it's
really cute like you guys
you're doing a part I don't know really
only be so so cool because I think it's
very cool because a lot there are a lot
of people that don't have a good feeling
about her in her style her body her
characteristic a song I think is so cool
did a good job when was the last time
you felt beautiful
[Music]
you don't know
how does it feel to be beautiful no I've
no idea I'd never thought about it how
you felt beautiful
really Oh freaking stop how did it feel
to be beautiful um feels it feels nice
to be called for them to go woman
empowerment uplifting others you know
spreading positivity thank you
that's okay that means a lot
[Music]
that's something I hear a lot of then my
girlfriend pushes private lines with
that being said it's it's one of those
things that you know doesn't matter who
you are where you're going through it's
just kind of like a light
I'm having a good day but you doing my
day even better I was having a bad day
you want to mean a good day
well thank you for life oh you're so
sweet
so you know it's an odd question to ask
I'm definitely a person that advocates
that your exterior is not as as
beautiful as your interior so it's it
sounds so weird I feel very fortunate
because I know there are people who
perhaps have you know disabilities or
have something that affects their facial
structure or the way that they look on
the outside but unfortunately we live in
like this materialistic world where
people even don't even get an
opportunity to showcase who they are and
I think that you know if there's
anything which perhaps maybe your
YouTube is doing it's really showing
people that it's all on the inside like
you could be the most beautiful ha
runway model but if you're a piece of
like no one cares but you could be the
sweetest person and like maybe not be
what society deems as like a covergirl
and I think that that's the best thing
that I feel like our whole culture
hopefully is actually starting to shift
towards and I hope that this video helps
too
cool
so that's pretty much it I'm and a
question for you is what do you think is
the most beautiful thing about you my
absolute
I am me I think my what I'm doing is the
most
[Music]
hey guys I just wanna let you know real
quick that I made some new sweaters and
I'm doing a giveaway on my Instagram so
find me on there and follow the
instructions on my most recent post to
enter other than that I just really want
to thank you guys I want to thank all
the new subscribers I've gone and the
subscribers that have been with me for a
while you guys don't understand how much
fun I have making these videos and it's
so cool to have a bigger audience to
share them with so thank you for that
and I think that's pretty much it I'll
see you guys next week
[Music]